je poirier bonjour bonjour quand on lit
votre livre ce qui est frappant on le
sait mais c'est l'étendue des nouveaux
cas d'alzheimer c'est une épidémie qui
croient rythme complètement fou après
exponentielle mathématiquement
exponentielle à la grandeur de la
planète et on a longtemps pensé que tu
veux mais lady nord américaine ou
occidental est ce qu'on découvre quand
on fait les projections pour les
quarante cinquante prochaines années
c'est non tiers monde que ça explose
parce que leur espérance de vie à eux
augmentent et qu'ils entrent dans la
fourchette d'âge où ça recommence vous
êtes 6 millions de chinois à l'heure
actuelle en fait vous dites que l' oms
smk schatz chaque 7 secondes
une jeune rock sur la planète sur la
planète rebond en amérique du nord c'est
des millions et des millions de 15,8
millions de cols millions de kayes en 1
millions presque au canada bon alors ça
c'est bon là on est choqué par son se
dit bon vin effectivement il y en a de
plus en plus ça ne ralentit pas du tout
non et la mauvaise nouvelle dans ce que
vous nous raconter c'est que les vaccins
ne fonctionne pas depuis 10 ans il ya eu
des échecs importants
c'est rare que des chercheurs le disent
aussi clairement là ça marche pas bah
ils n'ont un pige dans la défense des
chercheurs on ne dit écoutez ça s'en
vient ça bouge on est heureux on est
confiant mais ça fait moi ça fait quinze
ans le dernier médicament avoir été
approuvée en 2003 à plus de 15 ans on ne
fait plus de 165 étude de médicaments
phase iii ça veut dire après
l'approbation qui ont échoué donc c'est
pas qu'on n'a pas essayé mais qu'on n'a
pas réussi donc les vaccins pour
prévenir échec sur échec oui les
médicaments pour soulager ceux ci depuis
2003 c'est les mêmes médicaments les
mêmes ça soulage un peu mais pas très
longtemps pour longtemps on parle de 1 à
1 c'est pas chez tout le monde c'est
environ 30 à 40 % des cochers qui on va
voir un bénéfice qui est clair chez les
autres on doit se contenter d'un absence
de déclin temporaire et 1 30% chez qui
ça fait aucun effet si beaucoup de sous
que les pharmaceutiques
quand même on investit comment se
fait-il que c'est si difficile
dans votre livre qu'on n'a pas qui est
fascinant c'est que les animaux de
manière naturelle ne développe pas
l'alzheimer et contrairement au diabète
aux cancers et que ce qui rend la
recherche de médicaments plus difficiles
expliqué moins bon 1 les échecs on n'a
pas eu le choix quand on veut se doter
d'une cible thérapeutique
on cherche les choses qui fonctionnent
pas on s'est inspiré de la forme jeunes
agressive familiale dans cette forme
jeunes agressifs familial on a identifié
trop cause les gènes anormaux donc des
cibles thérapeutiques clair un défaut
vous aurez l'alzheimer n'y a pas de
défaut vous aurez pas les âmes
on s'est inspiré de ça malheureusement
pour traiter la forme commune celle qui
commence après 60 65
or c'est presque deux maladies
différentes
ce que je vous dis là c'est qu'on le
constate depuis une dizaine d'années
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on sait
depuis longtemps donc on se noie
concentrer nos énergies sur ces jeunes
cause hâtif et ce qu'on a fait on a créé
des modèles animaux avec les jeunes
cause hâtif la forme jeunes vous avez
induit la maladie chez des souris
fabrique mais dans sa forme à la main
pour jeunes jeunes croyants familiale
qui ont le guéry chez les souris à de
très nombreuses occasions
sauf que ça fonctionne pas c'est pas
salé biologie de la marque commune ça
fonctionne pas chez les patients qu'ils
développent de façon entre guillemets
normale normale des gens plus fort
manger et non seulement ça fonctionne
pas de certains médicaments qui ont tué
du monde
tactique en accéléré
la maladie alors ses échecs sur échecs
je perds ma question
dr poirier ou d'où viendra l'espoir il
vient de plusieurs endroits le premier
c'est quand on a regardé la génétique
que je vous rappelle les génétique c'est
60 à 65% la maladie d'alzheimer la forme
familiale d'un tout petit groupe serein
pour ça la forme normale la forme à
alger c'est leur s 98 99 % mais il ya
beaucoup de génétique même dans la forme
or et l'on nous on est rendu à 25 gènes
différents se sont pas déjà une causette
on les appelle les facteurs de risques
parce que vous êtes porteur du risque
mais sans un appariement d'un facteur
environnemental d'une anomalie qui est
lié à votre style de vie je donne un
exemple concret j'ai découvert une
vingtaine d'années un gène le gène
principal la maladie d'alzheimer forme
âgées mais si vous avez l'hypertension
combiné à ce jeune le vote risque est
multiplié par dix donc environnement
plus génétique
si ce qui distingue la forme jeunes
agressive ou le sait strictement la
génétique oui mais encore une fois on
sait ça mais sa chance à quel moment
pour autant arriver et va t'on un jour
arriver avec soin vaccins pour prévenir
ou une pilule pour guérir mais il le
faut faire le choix de changer de cible
thérapeutique
les pharmaceutiques vous savez ils sont
comme des moutons depuis 15 ans tout le
monde faisait l'analyse et de
développement de médicaments basés sur
la forme jeunes agressive tout les
pharmaceutiques à d'appoint qui
faisaient autre chose ça c'est la façon
de faire du pharmaceutique et l'homme
maintenant qu'on est plus ou moins que
tu es cette approche la l2 salle a
échoué à répétition on se concentre
maintenant sur les gènes associés à la
forme âgées mais aussi avec de nouvelles
méthodes d'analysé biologique qui vont
faire avancer au pied progrès vos
prévisions vous à quel est ce que un
jour y aura un traitement
je suis convaincu qu'on aura un
traitement mais il va être très très
différent de ce qu'on
ce qu'on attendait depuis dix ans est ce
que c'est pour bientôt je dois être
honnête non parce que ça prend dix ans
développé un traitement et je vois rien
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont nous amener ok
vous êtes honnête donc c'est pas demain
la veille 10 15 20 ans en attendant
qu'est ce qu'on fait d'abord vitamine c
vitamine à toutes sortes de choses on le
sait que sur le web le truc choses
circulent vous vous dites ça fonctionne
pas ça fonctionne pas et je le dis pas
simplement parce que c'est mon opinion
il ya eu des études avec placebo ou on a
regardé la vitamine c les vitamines e et
puis plein plein plein plein d'autres
choses et versus placebo ya aucun
bénéfice donc c'est fait dans les normes
de l'arc
mais si j'ai les jeunes si la génétique
france sauf chez harris dans les deux
coqs peut-être c'est vrai dans mon cas
et dans d'autres cas où si on fait quoi
meilleure alimentation du sport un peu
de vin rouge est la seule chose qu'on
peut faire
oui profiter de la vie mais sinon
d'aller les dernières 10 10 10 12 ans
qu'on a découvert c'est que des facteurs
de risque qu'on a longtemps longtemps
associé aux maladies cardiovasculaires
l'hypertension le cholestérol le diabète
l'apnée qui sont associés typiquement
aux maladies cardiovasculaires sont
devenus officiellement des facteurs de
risque maladie d'alzheimer la beauté de
soi c'est qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
progrès en cardio vasculaires on gère
l'hypertension laguérie pomme on la gère
très bien on gère le diabète qu'on
arrive à gérer tous ces facteurs liés
aux maladies cardiaques de façon très
agressive on enlève le risque alzheimer
en gérant ses facteurs très bien d'un
point où c'est un petit livre tout à
fait sa sainte et prouver que ça baise
entre sartre à potins ça atténue les
risques et la progrès en modération bien
sûr
mais évidemment on va se souhaiter des
jours meilleurs pour des traitements
mais il ya beaucoup de pharmaceutiques
qui cherchent à part ça va être une mine
d'or son profil est une mine d'or parce
qu'on me disait ça c'est exponentiel ya
énormément de cas et on vit de plus en
plus vieux et on est de plus en plus
nombreux avec dieu merci beaucoup ça m'a
fait vraiment une recherche
merci